because
um because you know a by-election might
bring in a fresh face for Rishi sunac
Nadine Dory is obviously a staunch Ally
of Boris Johnson Fresh Faces coming in
not a bad thing for Rishi Cena but
what's interesting it feels slightly to
me Liz a bit like when
um the resignations came in you know and
anger a denouncement came in against
Boris Johnson on that day when we saw
the sergeant Javid and um Richie sunac
resignations from cabinet and today
we're seeing a kind of flurry of kind of
Boris Johnson allies doing the same
similar to Rishi sunak well Rishi will
hope that these resignations and people
standing down from parliament are not as
damaging as those resignations were at
the time because of course in the end
that culminated in the end of
um Boris Johnson's Premiership but look
this is the the last thing really that
Rishi sunak wants I mean what we know
about the honors list
the word MPS that were potentially being
lined up for peerages including Nadine
dorries and you know the the rumor in
Westminster was that number 10 didn't
want those MPS to stand down now to
enter the Lords in the future and that
was because he didn't want to trigger
by-elections and all of this of course
is because the conservatives are still
doing really badly in the polls the last
thing they want to do is go to voters
and and have electoral contests that
especially in the run-up to a general
election because to be perfectly blunt
about it they are worried that they will
lose and so two by-elections is the last
thing on Rishi Su next list you know
we've seen him uh this week meeting
President Biden he's going out and about
on the world stage he wants to be seen
as a global leader in AI talking about
tech policy you know he is in the wake
of the the Boris Johnson Premiership and
then the Liz trust Premiership and he
has been trying to rebuild the
credibility Johnson will not go away
time and time again he's stealing the
Limelight as he has done tonight
um and and let's just remind our viewers
that Boris Johnson has quit as an MP he
has um uh curbed the Privileges
committee's ability to to to do that so
he he's released this statement
um it says I've received a letter from
the Privileges committee making it clear
much to my amazement that they are
determined to use the proceedings
against me to drive me out of parliament
what's interesting is further down he
says and and we should also say that he
says I take my responsibility seriously
I did not lie and I believe that in
their hearts the committee know it but
what's really interesting I've been
reading this it says their purpose from
the beginning has to been to find me
guilty regardless of the facts this is
the very definition of a kangaroo court
with extraordinary wording there for a
common privileges committee and then he
says most members of the committee
especially the chair had already
expressed deeply prejudicial remarks
about my guilt um actually uh let's
bring in Beth Rigby political editor of
course who's on the line with us too and
Beth an extraordinary turn of events
tonight Boris Johnson has decided to
quit as an MP
yeah I mean this is this is obviously a
huge moment for Westminster it was but
months ago that people thought that
Boris Johnson might even take another
Tilt at the leadership or should Rishi
sunac lose a general election could
Boris Johnson come back as leader of the
opposition but he tonight has announced
that he is stepping down from his
marginal seat with immediate effect
um
and and basically saying that he
believes that the privileged committee
is trying to drive him out of parliament
because they are going to recommend this
suspension of more than 10 days that
could trigger a recall petition that is
when uh if enough constituents decide
that they can force a by-election and
he's decided to take the ball by the
horns if you like and move fast uh but
this is a huge moment he's standing down
with immediate effect it's unclear about
what that means for his uh political
future might he try and uh return in
another seat at the next general
election simply don't know right now but
this obviously is an earthquake moment
in Westminster the the former prime
minister that people thought might have
another tilt up the leadership clearly
didn't want to be forced out of office
uh last July uh my the fact that he is
now uh standing down that huge
implications uh for the conservative
party
and for if you see that
and Beth let's talk about uh this in the
context of the conservative party
there's a there's a a part of the
statement that says we must not be
afraid to be a properly conservative
government
um what does this mean for Rishi Suna
just earlier today Nadine Doris resigned
as MP and she was of course a staunch
Ally and supporter of Boris Johnson
wanting him to make a comeback but now
he's resigned
well I think what this does is it it
blows open if you like some of the
tensions that have been simmering
between different wings of the party
about the Rishi sunak approach uh to tax
and spend uh taxes added post-war High
uh many conservatives agitate into tax
cuts but this a prime minister that is
trying to Grapple uh with these twin
pressures of avoiding recession and also
trying to drive down inflation interest
rates uh going up it really is a
difficult economic outlook for the Prime
Minister and in the in the letter there
is no doubt that Boris Johnson is is
taking a a swipe at the current prime
minister he says our party urgently
needs to recapture its sense of momentum
and its belief in what this country can
do he says we need to cut business and
personal taxes and not just as
pre-election gimmicks rather than
endlessly putting them up he then goes
on in a direct criticism if you like as
if she soon act to say why have we pre
passively abandoned the prospect of a
free trade bill with the US why have we
dumped measures to help people into
housing or Scrappy You directives or to
promote Animal Welfare so there's a
former prime minister deciding to quit
you know and and setting the house on
fire if you like as he goes I mean if
you think about what he's saying about
the Free Trade Agreement there this was
a conservative Manifesto promise of 2019
uh put in place by Boris Johnson
uh he promised in that Manifesto that
there would be a free trade deal with
the US by the end of 2022 you've seen
our reporting uh from Washington this
week in which this is very much on the
back burner with Lucy soon at completely
kind of giving up any attempt to even
try and put it onto the table uh with
President Biden and and the Prime
Minister extremely critical of that and
then and then when it comes to business
and personal taxes needing to cut them
he says not just as pre-election
gimmicks that's a a shot at Rishi soon I
gave the idea that he will you know try
and
personal taxation just ahead of an
election to try and drive a bit of
feel-good factor into the electorate in
the hope that they might swing for him
in the election
and what Boris Johnson is saying in
these in these criticisms is he he's
voicing what a lot of conservative uh
party members feel uh an MP seal but
which has kind of been kept under the
radar in a sort of effort for the party
to show some Unity
and I guess the big question that's
unknown and and this is the thing that
we will see unfold in the coming weeks
is what sort of Base does Boris Johnson
still have in the conservative party
that will rally against uh Rishi sunak
on this because you know as you said
Nadine Doris is leaving
um there are still some of his uh
supporters in the party but the fact
that Rishi soon Act was able to pass his
Windsor agreement on changing uh the
detail around the post-brexit Border uh
trading Arrangements uh in Northern
Ireland and there was meant to be a huge
uh Rebellion by
um brexiteers back in Boris Johnson and
in the end that Rebellion what it was
there but it wasn't momentous and so I
guess the question is is that if Boris
Johnson quits Parliament and the ring
leader goes who takes up the mantelism
to lose trust is it a pretty Patel he's
just been honored in uh Boris Johnson's
honors list so
um it's a huge moment and and we've got
to see how it plays about and whether
his departure and his direct attacks on
the Prime Minister uh really unsettle
and blow up potentially even this kind
of delicate truce that has been in the
Parliamentary party since Rishi sunak
became prime minister and since many
conservative companies realized that the
debacle of the trust regime
meant that however they felt about was
she sooner caught his policies they
needed to get behind this guy in order
just to settle the party and and and
look credible for the electorate and you
know how destabilizing will Boris
Johnson's bombshell be for issue sunak I
think we've got to see how that plays
out in the coming days it would be
interesting to see what people like
Zoella Bravo make of this given her her
what she was saying at the National
conservativism Conference not uh too
long ago I want to draw our viewers
attention Beth to another part of the
state statement where Boris Johnson
continues to say you know he's being
targeted we say we hear we've spoken
already with Liz and yourself about the
fact that he feels the Privileges
committee was determined to drive him
out of parliament he also goes on to
invoke a bit of brexit he says sadly as
we saw in July last year there are
currently some Tory MPS who share that
view I am not alone in thinking that
there is a Witch Hunt underway to take
revenge for brexit and ultimately to
reverse the 2016
referendum result I mean he's talking
about witch hunts and conspiracy
theories here
yeah I mean this is a very provocative
resignation letter and I haven't been I
mean it's just broken so I haven't been
through it in detail I think there is a
sense in the party and you saw this when
there was a decision which he alludes to
well actually doesn't allude to he he
references in the letter
um about the decision not to uh not to
sort of
um do away with a lot of EU legislation
which was a originally the plan uh that
there is a sense that he thinks that the
the brexit vision that he
set out or sought to set out in 2019
that it hasn't been followed through
um and that that basically that the the
current Administration even though Rishi
sunat was a brexitia
uh hasn't really honored
um
that that decision by the British people
and the commitment by the conservative
government
um to build this this post-brexit
economy and and you can see that quite
clearly in the way he criticizes which
is sooner over
um a trade agreement I think the
question is is whether uh Boris Johnson
is the kind of direct satyrian Chief if
you like uh rabble rousing like this in
what way it Stokes up division uh within
the Parliamentary party it's interest in
this because
the whole point of rece taking some
political uh heat quite frankly to prove
uh Boris Johnson's resignation list for
dozens of names on it uh it was meant to
be a peace offering if you like to kind
of Turn the page on the tensions between
a previous prime minister and a current
one and to try and unify the party and
to try and reassure those who were Boris
Johnson's backers that Rishi sunai did
not have an ax to grind against the
former prime minister but I think that
this very provocative letter has sort of
thrown that up up in the air really
because he he he is willing to kind of
take a fight not just to the
privilegious committee but but to heart
to the heart of number 10 as well
yeah and Beth let's talk about what um
well I mean it's speculation isn't it
but what he might do next we I I
mentioned the national conservatism
conference um of course Nadine Doris and
supporters like her always wanted Boris
Johnson to kind of make a comeback are
we potentially seeing a a splinter group
of of the Tory party and uh
a sideline party coming out of this
I mean it's just simply too early to
speculate in that way
um
the the Grassroots movement that has
been set up uh by Boris Johnson
supporters is a is a movement uh within
the party uh to try to get back to what
someone will likely to Patel would would
describe as the Grassroots operations
um what Boris Johnson does and whether
he still sees he has a political career
I think there's lots of questions here
does he now resign from Uxbridge and try
and come back in another seat I don't
know I mean he he could do that if he
chose to he could maybe try and go for
Mid beds with Nadine I mean there are
lots of conservative associations
um that would be delighted to have Boris
Johnson as their uh Member of Parliament
doesn't decide uh that this is it now
and that he wants to go and make even
more money than he's made since uh
leaving office and and sort of move out
of public life I mean the thing I would
say
is that the the positioning of that
letter is not someone who wants to go
quietly or thinks the game is up in the
sense that he is throwing down a number
of gauntlets about how he thinks
brexit's been done wrong uh how he
thinks Rishi sunak is not uh run in the
conservative party and government in the
way that he thinks it should uh and what
he thinks could be done better and
differently and you know you have to say
that as an observer that has has
followed him closely uh for many many
years that's the sign of of someone
that's you know perhaps preparing for
another chapter in some guys I should
say I have checked with his people to
try and um to try and get some sense of
of what's going on
um in terms of what he does next and
they're saying at the moment that they
have nothing further to add to the
statement that Boris Johnson has just
put out
um okay and Beth uh let's talk about uh
let's take it back to this statement how
it started and the criticism of the
Privileges committee and the people on
it including of course the chair Harriet
Harman
um what does it mean for a former prime
minister to to uh to attack and and
criticize a privileges Committee in this
way
well look I think that look I think the
point about the privileged committee and
Boris Johnson is from the very get-go
um there were questions uh put out by
the Johnson Camp about the legitimacy of
the committee the the political angling
of the committee
um the way in which the committee was
trying to expand the remit these were
all arguments put forward uh by the
Boris Johnson team even going into this
um these hearings
um so it was already extremely tense and
the one thing I remember when I was
covering it that that we that we
stressed was that if Boris Johnson came
out of the process uh with a heavy
sanction and there was talk about
whether or not in the end the committee
might you know slap him on the wrist but
but not recommend
the the most stringent of sanctions
which was a 10 plus day suspension which
could trigger a by-election that that
was the kind of dynamite moment and
would the committee sort of step back
from that now it's clear from what they
have said to him that they haven't uh
when I was reporting about that
committee and listening to the hearings
I mean the thing that I picked up uh
from those around him and those who
supported him
was that he questioned the legitimacy
anyway and and certainly if the findings
uh landed in a way that was really
detrimental to him that he would you
know that he would challenge the
legitimacy of the committee so it it
doesn't it doesn't surprise me uh that
that is where we ended up he was
challenging the legitimacy of this going
into the hearings uh and it's it turned
out in a way that is really really
damaging to him uh so he has you know
questioned the legitimacy of the
committee I mean I think that that was
to be honest to be expected
Beth for the moment uh thank you stay
with us though where we'll be coming
back to you no doubt um uh if you're
watching Sky News and you've just tuned
in we are bringing you the breaking news
that Boris Johnson has quit as an MP he
stands down effective immediately he's
released a damning statement of his
treatment by the Privileges committee
and says this is a Witch Hunt against
him
um uh let's uh speak to former adviser
to David Cameron of course the former
Prime Minister David Cameron Sarah
Southern who joins me on the line now
and and Sarah I know that you've managed
to have a brief look at this lengthy
statement
um he says uh I'm very sorry to leave my
wonderful constituency it's been a huge
honor I'm very sad to leave Parliament
at least for now but above all I am
bewildered and appalled that I can be
forced out what do you make of this
it is quite the statement and it it's
it's quite bruising in some ways in you
know the way that he named Sue gray and
he names Harriet Harman but of course he
has got that little twist at the end of
saying I'm leaving Parliament for now
um it's come as quite a surprise I don't
think anyone was expecting this to
happen at this stage I think there was
definitely a surprise that Boris Johnson
had said that he would stand again for
Parliament at the next election but I
don't think we're expecting him to keep
the drama this High constantly
yeah uh constantly in Rishi Sue next
where he constantly stealing the
headlines from Rishi sunak and what do
you think the response will be inside
number 10 tonight
well I can't imagine they're going to be
very pleased uh you know I think that
when the um resignation honors list came
out at what about five o'clock this
evening everyone was obviously pouring
through that and wondering what it meant
when certain names weren't on there and
you know how it had been held up what on
Earth had number 10 been doing who
they've been taking off and then
obviously Nadine dorries then stands
down triggering a by-election then you
think well that's not going to have uh
improved anybody's moods as by-elections
are expensive and you know very time
consuming for political parties across
the board and then three hours later the
former prime minister resigned so I
can't imagine that Richie sonak has come
back from the states expecting such you
know chaos to be reigning uh so it will
definitely have come as quite the
surprise
yeah and Boris Johnson
um making several statements within this
statement of his dismay of how matters
political matters and policy matters are
being handled but pretty critical really
of of the way his mantle has been
carried forwards um and says I'm looking
for the part now in this lengthy
statement you know why have we so
passively abandoned the prospect of a
free trade deal with the us we need to
deliver on the 2019 Manifesto which was
endorsed by 14 million people of course
where he won the biggest majority in 40
years
um uh so he's he's he's leaving but he's
also kind of making it pretty clear his
opinion on rishi's statements Rishi
sunak for tenure
absolutely it does feel as though he's
dropped quite a few grenades in that
statement and made us feelings very
clear he's clearly very unhappy with the
Privileges committee he doesn't feel as
though he's kind of had a fair go at
that and I think he's kind of really
used this as an opportunity to to make
his feelings very clear towards the
current prime minister which obviously
he hasn't been able to do on the back
benches so I do feel that this isn't
going to be the final
um bit of information we get out of
Boris Johnson on his feelings towards
this when he's now not an MP he's
obviously going to be able to be a lot
Freer and a lot more vocal I would
imagine and what his feelings are with
the government currently
yeah so do you think that's part of it
so that he can be Freer to speak I mean
he's been very critical even in this
statement of the Privileges committee
which I I don't know about you but it
struck me as a an MP to be very critical
of of a committee that has a right to
investigate what an MP says and does
absolutely and certainly kind of in the
quick read through that I've given of
the statement it felt as though
initially that the first few paragraphs
it's as though he's just come to the end
of his tether as it were with the
Privileges committee and he doesn't like
the way that he's been treated now
whether he's right or wrong in that
isn't kind of for us to decide but he's
obviously got to the point where he's
thinking I'm not going to allow you the
Privileges committee to determine the
outcome of what I'm going to be doing
I'm going to take control the easiest
way for me to do that is to just step
away caller by-election not be in
Parliament anymore
um whether that is the end of his
political Journey
who's to know
right Sarah Southern for now thanks very
much indeed um let's bring back in our
political correspondent who's sitting
here in the studio with me Liz Bates and
and Liz I mean what a day we started
with um Nadine Dory saying she's not
going to resign she won't trigger a
by-election then Nadine dory's
triggering a by-election by resigning
quite dramatically and then this evening
we're talking about Donald Trump
um talking about a Witch Hunt and now
we've got our former prime minister here
in the UK Boris Johnson less than a year
after he was forced to resign as prime
minister resigning as an MP standing
down with immediate effect and I I mean
this is huge huge news uh this evening
it was shocking to read it when that
statement came out and look Boris
Johnson is a politician we are
completely accustomed to him doing
things that shock us but he still has
the capacity uh to surprise us with this
statement tonight we knew that there
there could be a bit of a standoff
between him and the Privileges committee
especially if they recommended a more a
suspension over 10 days which it seems
like they were going to do Boris Johnson
has long said that this privileges
committee investigation was
um a Witch Hunt despite there being I
think it's four conservative members of
parliament on that committee but I don't
think anyone was expecting him to react
like this to resign with immediate
effect to trigger a violation the
by-election is quite interesting so we
were talking earlier today about Nadine
dory's
um she's in mid bedfordshire she has a
huge majority in that seat so that's
potentially an annoyance to number 10
um it would have to be a huge collapse
in the conservative vote there for them
to lose that seat Boris Johnson's seat
is very different I've just been looking
at it so there he has a majority of 7
000. yes and it's the labor party the
tasked second by quite a long way in
that constituency so that is going to be
a very difficult fight for the
conservative party on current polling
and in a by-election scenario
um I think they they they would not back
themselves
um at this point that would be difficult
I think for them to hang on to at the
current polling it all depends on who
stands or the context things can change
very quickly but this is a totally
totally different Prospect from mid
bedfordshire I mean they could they
could easily lose that seat
extraordinarily so the labor party could
well be cheering for that tonight
um um I want to draw attention and I I
read it earlier but once again let's
let's just remind
um our viewers of the last line of this
statement as Forrest Johnson
um stands down as an MP and has quit
um he said it is very sad to be leaving
Parliament at least for now there you go
it's underlined in red on your screens
right now I was speaking to guito Harry
um just a few weeks ago Liz and and he
said well you know I asked him what do
you reckon Boris Johnson's going to do
and he said oh well he did say hasta la
vista baby and again we've got the same
thing at least for now that's exactly
the moment that came into my mind when I
read at least for now it reminded me of
that moment in Parliament where Boris
Johnson uh having been forced start by
his own party after maybe over a year of
Scandal and in typical Boris Johnson
fashion he didn't seem to be
particularly humbled by the
circumstances of his departure and
instead a kind of veiled theatrical
threat that he would return to politics
Frontline politics we thought at the
time because he was going to the back
benches and now the same thing in this
statement the suggestion that he will be
back and I think for people that know
Boris Johnson he he doesn't have a huge
amount of you know a huge social life
outside of politics he is very much a
um a committed
if you like a politician he loves being
in politics he loves being at the center
of attention she mentioned the theatrics
there I mean if you read this statement
you can hear his voice and you know the
outrage with which he is disappointed in
how the Privileges committee is is
driving him out I mean I'm sure we're
going to have it on our website so
anyone who wants to read the whole
statement will be able to
um so you know do read it with Boris
Johnson's voice you can clearly see him
coming through it um let's bring Beth
Rigby our political editor back in Beth
I understand you may well have more
information
um on Boris Johnson quitting as MP
tonight
well what what I have done is I've
spoken to a couple of his closest allies
and I can tell you uh that even those uh
politicians who are close to him uh have
been shocked by this statement tonight
uh so people around him did not know it
was coming and people are shot uh one
person said I didn't know he was
planning uh to do this
um and then why has he done it now I
think that uh
from my conversations with people that
that know him well
um there's a sort of view that given
that um
Parliament could have voted to suspend
him he has sort of seized sees that sees
the moment and and taken control uh and
resigned before he went through what is
a extremely humiliating process for him
uh in which he was sanctioned then
suspended by the House of Commons
um as for a comeback
um I think that that is a very Live
question amongst those uh that are close
to him uh one person saying to me he's
simply just too big a figure in politics
not to be involved uh there's questions
about whether he having stepped down now
and resigned he's triggered a
by-election in Uxbridge uh whether he uh
perhaps stands in that by-election
perhaps or he goes and stands in another
seat and you were referencing the bit at
the end of the letter where it said uh
something about uh being gone for now
um so I think there's a very Live
question tonight about whether this
resignation is a reaction
to what was going to be a public
humiliation by Boris Johnson and he
Furious uh with the Privileges committee
has decided to preempt them and Take
Back Control if you like of his own uh
political fate and resigned before he
was suspended and potentially had a
by-election triggered and then there's a
broader question about whether he might
come back the remarks about issue sooner
the criticisms of uh his policies around
tax and spend or brexit sort of signal a
politician
um that still has a lot of fuel in his
tank whether he comes back as an MP
whether he comes back as a columnist I
think that you know it's clear that that
he's not going to go quietly and that um
that that he still has despite all his
detractors and despite the controversy
around him uh an ability to pull in a
huge audience and make impact in what he
does knows
yes Beth exactly I mean we we were
discussing earlier when we first heard
that um about the statement and him
stepping down Liz and I that this is a
preemptive strike really but not just a
preemptive strike the statement also
includes a lot of criticisms of how uh
the current government and the
conservative parties is carrying itself
how Rishi sunac is um carrying the party
forwards critical of the trade deal
critical of not following the 2019
Manifesto
um clearly Boris using this moment to
say all the things potentially he
couldn't have said before to be critical
of someone who's very dissatisfied with
who's taken over from him
yeah look I think I'm just I'm just
looking through the letter as well and
the last paragraph it is very sad to be
leaving Parliament at least for now and
that is a very clear indication from
Boris Johnson
um that this is not a permanent
departure isn't it and it takes me back
uh to when he gave his final prime
minister's questions and uh he did the
uh he did the hasta la vista baby you
know
um you know but I'll be back type
uh type sentiment and I I really think
that
the more I look at this it's very
unclear about whether this is the
departure of Boris Johnson from
Frontline politics or whether this is a
specific uh decision by him uh in light
of what the privilegious committee
um has done uh to to to decide to
control his Destiny for now in order to
keep his powder dry to come back uh at
another date and I think that within the
letter
she is it's a it's a rallying cry if you
like uh to a number of conservatives on
the back benches who are dissatisfied
with Rishi sunak uh are unhappy about
the direction of the conservative party
and and he is he is he is calling to
those people and
um signaling to them that you know I I
will lead this charge against the Prime
Minister on these issues so so I think
that you know
squishy Scenic on the one hand might
think I'm glad to see the back of him as
as the MP for Oxbridge uh but the
question is is whether he comes back in
another seat and whether having been
relatively quiet and not trying to you
know poke The Hornet's Nest uh whether
he comes back in a much more disruptive
way which would be the last thing that
the Prime Minister needs I mean I was
speaking to one of his team when we were
in Washington
um about kind of the past six months and
then passing complicated legislation
around most recently uh small boats and
how relieved they were and please they
were that they had managed to parole the
party despite these obvious tensions
between soon actor Johnson to trust
um you know and this figure reminded me
they said you know the point is going
into a general election is divided
parties do not win elections we have to
be unified and it just feels to me
tonight whether this is a moment where
Boris Johnson's decided he might just
want to blow it all up
okay Beth Rigby political editor sir
thanks very much indeed for the moment
if you're tuning in to Sky News uh we
have some breaking news here this
evening Boris Johnson has stood down and
quit with immediate effects as MP with a
scathing statement I'm going to bring
you clips from that now I'm reading it
to you in the statement issued this
evening Boris Johnson said I have been
an MP since 2001. I take my
responsibilities seriously I did not lie
and I believe that in their hearts the
committee know it that is of course
referring to the Privileges committee
investigating whether he misled
Parliament he goes on but they have
willfully chosen to ignore the truth
because from the outset their purpose
has not been to discover the truth or
genuinely to understand what was in my
mind when I spoke in the Commons
their purpose from the beginning has
been to find me guilty regardless of the
facts this is the very definition of a
kangaroo court it is a very sad it is
very sad to be leaving Parliament at
least for now but above all I am
bewildered and appalled that I can be
forced out anti-democratically
fire committee chaired and managed by
Harriet Harman was such egregious bias
well let's bring in our Deputy political
editor Sam coats is in the studio with
me tonight um Sam there's a lot to
digest in this statement
um a lot of accusations there what do
you make of all of this
so here we have Boris Johnson departing
Parliament for the second time he of
course stood down uh to be London bear
once before so he is a man that has
shown he can come back but I do Wonder
this is a resignation letter written in
Rage it's written in Rage that finds
fault with so many so many on his own
side so many in the civil service so
many uh on the opposition benches he
feels trapped like a caged animal a
victim of what he appears to suggest is
a mass conspiracy against him and in the
light of that overwhelming Force that's
being deployed against him he now feels
that there is no option but to stand
down and Trigger our by-election in his
Uxbridge constituency
now I actually wonder whether what we're
witnessing tonight is the end of Boris
Johnson as a big political figure in our
politics because
if you just pull the camera back a bit
you know this was a figure who didn't
really have the numbers in Parliament he
was out of parliament a lot earning huge
amounts of money in speeches there was
an alternative path for him he has no
chance really of becoming the leader of
the opposition his best Hope was to be
the kind of media click bait and uh the
kind of fandom guy of a small number of
Tory MPS but that is not a path that
takes you back to being Tory leader his
prospects for the top job are probably
over so the best he could do was hang
around in politics probably get
Headlines by undermining which is soon
that get Headlines by undermining
whoever took over from Richardson lose
the next election and becomes leading
the opposition and sort of stay like the
kind of ghost at The Feast for years and
years and years is that a good enough
feature for Boris Johnson gonna say is
that good enough for Boris Johnson he's
sorry bear with us we've just got a
statement in from Angela Rayner labors
that leader and Shadow Chancellor of the
duchy of Lancaster of course she's
released a statement saying the British
public are sick to the back teeth of
this never-ending Tory soap opera played
out at their expense after 13 years of
conservative chaos enough is enough
it's time to turn the page with a fresh
start for Britain with a labor
government focused on the people's
priorities of tackling the cost of
living crisis and building a better
future Sam I mean
a lot of this is often to do with the
infighting inventory party isn't it and
the differing views and they can't seem
to agree on on what to do and how to go
forwards and Boris Johnson as you say
making this explosive kind of petulant
statement No and look this is going to
trigger a period of you know instability
a period of of of of kind of mid-level
Civil War I I I I let's put let's put it
in context because the last few years
have been extraordinary in British
politics I think it's it's important to
say what what tonight it doesn't feel
like it doesn't feel like the beginning
of a coup it doesn't feel like uh the uh
there is any serious attempt to any
discussion that you know people might
come for Rishi sunak as a result of this
action there will be grumbling there
will be anger amongst a minority of Tory
MPS about uh what they think of as being
an assault on Boris Johnson who won that
2019 election that they see is
unnecessary uh you know some of the
reactions you've heard um uh you've seen
Simon Clark saying well said Boris
Johnson uh I've been lead to WhatsApp
message from Andrea Jenkins again in
which she says agree well done Rishi for
starting this nonsense right so that's a
criticism where she's doing that for the
role that she perceives Richard simack
has played in getting to where we are by
the way Downing Street deny that
um but but that from Andrew Jenkins who
is just about the biggest supporter of
Boris Johnson he's not more aggressive
than than that it's not a declaration of
war it's a it's a sort of grumpy
Outburst Simon Clark another massive
supporter of Boris Johnson quite you
know restrained in the way that he's
talking about it there is going to be a
general election next year and so every
conservative MP looking to how to
respond to tonight's extraordinary news
you know off the back of months and
months of extraordinary touring uh Tory
uh developments have to calibrate
whether or not uh they're going to go
full against Downing Street and my
calculation from early conversations
that they don't
okay Sam Clark thanks very much indeed
it's some coat sorry I'm I've got too
many MPS names going tonight and uh and
let's bring in another one Michael
Fabric and fabricant has just um I'm
guessing tweeted and my producer uh
Johnny's just sent this to me it says
disgraceful treatment of a political
leader who has made world history by
achieving brexit and leading the
conservatives to a landslide general
election Victory I I understand I I
think that we can now also bring in
former government Minister Anna subri
who joins us with her reaction tonight
to Anna subri this was once your party
the conservative party what do you make
of what's going on tonight
shameful moment though there's some joy
that Boris Johnson is standing down as
Member of Parliament I think it's really
important to remind everybody that this
privileges committee has a conservative
majority it includes people art
conservatives like subura Jenkins and
the idea that this is some sort of
stitch up is for the birds Boris Johnson
clearly thought that not only had he
lost the confidence of that conservative
biased majority on that committee but
also he wasn't confident that when it
went that report went into the House of
Commons clearly wasn't confident that he
would get the support within the House
of Commons it's a bit like a toddler
throwing their toys out of the pram and
so he stepped down leaving his poor
constituents in in yet more difficulty
having no doubt served them particularly
badly over the time that he's been their
their member but I think there's
something else in with this and look I'm
not the biggest fan of Angela Rayner but
I think she's put a finger absolutely on
it you know tonight across the country
there'll be many families wondering if
they're going to make it next week when
it look when they look at their family
budget the cost of living crisis is real
for people right across our country from
all sorts of backgrounds and yet yet
again what we see is a psychodrama in
the conservative party when frankly
there are bigger issues that a
government a responsible government
should be looking at and addressing and
being there to help people and instead
we have this pathetic fast
generated as ever by the great egotist
and charlatan Boris Johnson
well you don't mention your words there
tonight Anna so um let's talk about
Boris Johnson's statement and and the
kind of as Sarah Southern put it earlier
the grenades he's thrown in his his way
because he resigns as MP you know
criticizing where she Sue next policy
criticizing the lack of a U.S trade deal
you know Sky News covered that uh from
Washington this week um Chris is
critical that his 2019 Manifesto hasn't
been carried forwards
um what damage do you think he's managed
to do to Rishi soon act tonight
well I mean I think the thing is as Beth
Rigby quite rightly identified you're
Beth with Rigby said you know voters
don't like divided parties and and that
is what they will take away from all of
this they they're frankly I don't think
they're really interested in the nuances
of of of whether or not Richie sunac has
delivered on a brexit deal with
um America that was promised in the 2019
Manifesto I mean I would say being you
know with the views that I do about
brexit which is another terrible lie
that was actually told by people like
Boris Johnson but but actually what
matters is that as far as the electorate
you know your viewers real ordinary folk
are concerned is that this is a divided
party a divided government and there's
your bathroom be rightly identified
people don't like that they want a
government frankly that they can look at
almost out of the corner of their eyes
as they get on with their ordinary lives
and they can think well they rustling
you know share my values but most
importantly they're competent they're
just getting on with a job and yet again
they're not because they're deeply
divided yet again there's this
distraction by that man Boris Johnson
and you know it's also the case I think
but it's like you know yet again
everything he touches
just goes bad and wrong and I think
um will he we've got we've got about 30
seconds for your answer Anna subri but
um do you think he'll make a comeback
look when he resigned as prime minister
he said hasta la vista baby and now
tonight as he's resigned as MP he said I
am now being forced out of parliament by
a tiny handful of people
um and uh I I am going for now
no look he's been four starved actually
by conservative majority committee and
he knows he won't win the vote in
Parliament which of course is dominated
by the conservative party let's be clear
on that look he's a man who needs a
platform he he needs he he thrives on
the oxygen of publicity so what on Earth
he'll do next I do not know so in some
ways I don't care but I do actually
because I care passionately about having
people involved in politics that are
decent and honest and honorable and
don't tell lies that is not that man
Boris Johnson so if he was to disappear
from British policy it's good that would
be good for British politics
very much indeed stay tuned to Sky News
as we cover this breaking news Boris
Johnson has stood down as an MP stay
with us for more at the top of the hour
with Anna Jones
well good evening the former prime
minister Boris Johnson as you've heard
has announced he is standing down as an
MP with immediate effect in a statement
the former prime minister said he has
received the findings from the
Privileges committee report into whether
he misled MPS over party goat so let's
look at the crucial excerpts then from
that statement he says I have been an MP
since 2001. I take my responsibility
seriously I did not lie and I believe
that in their hearts the committee know
it but they have willfully chosen to
ignore the truth because from the outset
their purpose has not been to discover
the truth or genuinely to understand
what was in my mind when I spoke in the
House of Commons their purpose from the
beginning has been to find me guilty
regardless of the facts this is the very
definition of a kangaroo court it is
very sad to be leaving Parliament at
least for now but above all I am
bewildered and appalled that I can be
forced out
anti-democratically by a committee
chaired and managed by Harriet Harman
with such egregious bias well let's
bring in our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates who joins me live you described
it as what a resignation letter in Anger
Sam
that's right it's an enormous moment
tonight Anna you have effectively an end
of an era Boris Johnson who
you know just in the middle of last
summer in last Autumn was the UK's prime
minister now choosing to resign as a
member of parliament quitting his
Uxbridge seat with immediate effects
triggering a by-election causing an
enormous headache for his successor as
prime minister but Juan Rishi sunak uh
tonight because he cannot see a way that
he can survive politically the
Privileges committee uh report into his
conduct whether he lied to Parliament
the decision by that majority uh
conservative
committee which has found that he was
guilty of lying and have decided that he
should be suspended for more than 10
days which in turn triggers would have
triggered a by-election in his Uxbridge
constituency uh which he would fight um
he he now feels he cannot fight perhaps
because he does not feel that he can win
it so rather than face the commons and
face his constituents tonight Boris
Johnson has announced that he is
quitting as an MP it's a sensational uh
letter from him he feels quite clearly
across the 1500 words angry he feels
enraged by the forces that he see line
up against him he feels uh cornered by
an array of internal and external
critics whether it's people that oppose
them inside the conservative party and
makes quite clear he thinks the
government's going in the wrong
direction and he thinks that Rishi sunak
isn't taking the Tory party down the
right path but also external enemies
people that he once Works alongside like
Sue gray the civil servant uh who headed
the last inquiry to Boris Johnson's
conduct now going to work for kierstama
whether it's other figures on the
Privileges committee that he blames uh
whether it's Harriet Harman the labor
mother of the house who chaired the
Privileges committee all of these people
He suggests have been working to cast
him out but I wonder Anna whether the
real reality of today's decision is that
in the end Boris Johnson had to take the
decision that he took because he doesn't
have the political clout that he had
just two or three years ago he doesn't
have the numbers in Parliament he
perhaps doesn't have the backing of the
constituents he was in Knox bridge I
think only a few days ago posting social
media videos uh out campaigning yet
today has decided he doesn't want to
face uh potentially face constituents if
MPS voted along the lines that uh the
Privileges committee was going to uh was
going to was going to recommend and as
such he has he has decided to go taking
pot shots in all uh directions in in
some ways Boris Johnson's resignation
letter reminded me a little bit of the
way that Dominic Robb left government
angry and taking chunks out of everybody
from every angle that's what Boris
Johnson has done kind of on you know in
in on speed and effectively in this uh
in this letter
um He suggests that he is quitting for
now I have to say it's extreme
ordinarily difficult to see anyway back
for him in future you have a prime
minister slung from office as prime
minister by the conservative party
because of their conduct then found
guilty of lying to Parliament by a
conservative dominated privileges
committee and not what not wishing to
face his constituency has uh
constituents has now left from
Parliament can he come back to
Parliament a third time in the future
well given that the kind of track record
it seems to be very hard to imagine in
some senses what's going on I think Anna
is that Boris Johnson has quit in in
some ways to avoid that kind of reality
check that reality test and instead sort
of to some degree preserve the myth of
his Premiership he was hanging over the
shoulders uh of Rishi United she was
hanging out over uh Liz truss he would
continue if not leader than to suck the
oxygen the publicity the media loved
Boris Johnson there's no doubting about
that for whoever if the Tories lose the
next general election whoever came next
whoever said succeeded Rishi soon
actually have to stand down and I think
in that reality Boris Johnson's role if
he stayed in Parliament was to be a
Perpetual irritant to whoever was in
charge of the conservative party but
there probably was no path back to him
doing something more than that so to
preserve his reputation as the man that
won that extraordinary general election
victory in 2019 took the country through
covert and delivered the vaccine and
then was effectively something of a
wartime leader steering the country
through Ukraine he now wants to depart
on his own terms saying that he's been
Thrust out by enemies working against
him in a conservative party not willing
to stick up for it but I think the
reality is he just cannot rely on people
on his own side to protect him against
the full force of what's about to hit
him with this privileges committee vote
well I had looked forward he said to
providing enthusiastic support as a
backbench MP notwithstanding what you
said as a Perpetual irritant he went on
to say Harriet harman's committee has
set out to make that objective
completely untenable the committee's
report is riddled with inaccuracies and
reeks of prejudice but under their
absurd and unjust process I have no
formal ability to challenge anything
they say he goes on to say that many or
most members of the committee especially
the chair had already expressed deeply
prejudiced remarks about my guilt before
they'd even seen the evidence they
should have recused themselves there's a
lot of anger in this but we woke up
didn't we to headlines that peerages in
his honors list would be scrapped in
order to avoid by-elections and here we
are with two that's right um very
important to say by the way Downing
Street denied that Rishi sunak deed
remove alok Sharma and Nadine Doris from
the peerages list they say that the
peridot's list uh that went uh to the
king for approval was the one submitted
by the committee that kind of vets these
things so there is a sort of gap between
what allies of Boris Johnson claim uh
happened over the last 36 hours and what
uh allies of Rishi sunak uh say but
nevertheless Boris Johnson has gone on a
day that he has installed quite a lot of
his supporters uh in the House of Lords
we saw figures like Ben houchton uh go
there he's the teas Valley mayor
um he's uh he's got his press secretary
uh uh has also uh has also gone there
you know in some senses the House of
Lords is the alternative uh Center where
quite a lot of Boris supporters Boris
Johnson supporters have ended up as a
former prime minister could he end up in
the House of Lords I think that's an
interesting question to chew on in the
next couple of days but I think the main
focus the next couple of days will be
just how much Fallout is there in the
conservative party over Boris Johnson's
resignation now to my mind the kind of
response from allies of Boris Johnson
apart from Natty Doris but for most
allies of Boris Johnson has been
relatively calibrated not to sort of
trigger internal War inside the
conservative party but I mean we could
nevertheless
get ministerial resignations or MPS
standing down just to try and give some
momentum to the uh to the kind of uh to
the trouble that Boris Johnson is
causing Rishi sunak tonight but I think
that there is a lid there is a ceiling
on the amount of difficulty that even if
he wants to Boris Johnson can uh can
inflict on the current prime minister
simply because of the political reality
that we are a year maybe a little bit
more out from a general election the
conservative party are well behind in
the polls they are trying many many MPS
who want to want to cling on are trying
to uh do what they can to put the party
in the best possible position in order
to do well in the next general election
and doing that would mean not backing a
kind of devices in divisive inflammatory
internal row of the sort that we've had
pretty much the last two years in the
conservative party keeping a lead on the
infighting that you could see triggered
by this uh this resignation and just try
and carry on uh Angry as they might be
uh furious with Rishi sunak as they
might be but nevertheless not tearing
another conservative Administration down
because uh of how allies of Boris
Johnson perceive that he has been
treated so I think that there is a
ceiling to how much trouble this is
going to cause it's going to be a very
very very painful weekend for the
conservative party and in into next week
but but in six months time out I do
wonder whether we look back at this and
you see that Boris Johnson probably had
no path back to being conservative
leader probably had no uh real future as
a big figure in the Tory party uh for
him he was making he's making huge sums
uh doing corporate work doing speeches
millions of pounds uh every every bit of
which has to be disclosed on the public
register there is possibly a path for
him uh to be joining the House of Lords
did he really want to be the person who
uh was hanging around the conservative
disrupting successive Tory leaders by
always being the person that got the
media attention at the spotlight hogged
for month after month or did he decide
actually because he doesn't have the
support in Parliament to actually make a
real challenge to the incumbent whatever
he thinks of him he cannot be sure that
he'd win that Uxbridge by-election uh
the majority of which is probably not
large enough to really be able to rely
on I'm instead tonight has quit to
preserve the myth of what Boris Johnson
wants the Boris Johnson Legacy to be
7210 I think that Oxbridge majority for
Boris Johnson Sam for the moment thank
you very much Lee let's bring in now the
deputy editor of conservative home Henry
Hill who joins me live so is this the
end of Boris Johnson as a political
force and if so should we care
I mean I I predicted the downfall of
Boris Johnson so many times that I need
to caveat this extremely heavily but
probably right I mean he's leaving he's
leaving Parliament now I don't see Rishi
Cena giving him a path back at the next
general election and then after that
he's not in a position if he were in
Parliament and the conservatives lost
the next election there were certainly
Pathways in which he could become leader
of the opposition but now he's not going
to be there at that crucial moment so
yes at least in this particular
iteration of Frontline politics it does
look like he's probably done he can
still be a destabilizing force you know
he could get a TV show that seems to be
the current informatory MPS at the
moment but he won't be in Parliament and
that is
probably in the long run a relief for
Richie sooner
we threw this extraordinary letter that
he's issued
um you know the sum up of it for me
would be first of all I did nothing
wrong uh he's being stitched up he talks
about a Witch Hunt and a hit job he's a
proven winner in the polls and he's
effectively being junked wrongly he was
supportive of Liz truss's agenda he
wants a program growth and low tax Tory
party and real frustration to it Rishi
sunax government on that free trade deal
abandonment with the US on housing on
Animal Welfare
um you know what was what's your reading
of it
well I mean it's it's fascinating to
hear all of these like really detailed
policy positions that Bryce Johnson has
if only he'd had a chance to be prime
minister and do something about any of
these issues that exercise him so much
the fact of the matter is that he the
one of the one of the reasons that he
stopped being prime minister is that we
had three years of spinning wheels right
he didn't make progress on any of this
he didn't even table a retained EU law
bill it was left to Liz trust to do that
and then Rishi sooner to junk it but
yeah ultimately there's a lot of people
who are still prepared to buy into the
idea of Boris Johnson the great winner
the great vision read the great talker
about if not builder of sort of grand
projects and infrastructure and all the
rest of it so that is why or at least
one of the reasons why he's going and in
the same way that you know lady Thatcher
never lost an election and therefore
homose committed supporters could always
just say that she was never beaten
although she would definitely have lost
in 1992 in the same way because he was
never asked to fight a general election
with his old polling which he would have
lost it because he now has not dared
divided by election which recent polling
suggests he would actually have won
which would have given his career a huge
shot in the arm again he's chosen to
back out so I think we need to take
Boris Johnson as his own estimation
Boris Johnson's estimation is ultimately
that he doesn't think that he has a way
back he doesn't think that he can retain
the confidence of the voters of Uxbridge
despite polling to the contrary
um and I can understand why he's angry
about that but ultimately Parliament has
to self-police MPS keep complaining that
the internal procedures are not like a
trial and they're not like an employment
for tribunal but Parliament is
fundamentally different Parliament is a
is a is a representative body you can't
have normal HR procedures it has to some
extent to police itself he's made a lot
of wild allegations about the inquiry
we'll have to see what its report says
but he has not substantiated them so far
well and
indeed about the findings of this
committee they have still not produced a
shred of evidence that I knowingly or
recklessly misled the commons they know
perfectly well that when I spoke in the
Commons I was saying what I believe
sincerely to be true they know that I
corrected the record as soon as possible
and they know that I and every other
senior official and Minister including
the current prime minister and then
occupant of the same building Rishi
sunag believed that we were working
lawfully together so fundamentally at
the root of this he does not believe the
tale of partygate he thought he was in
groups working in Downing Street
yeah but I mean the best possible
version of the Boris Johnson story is
that people were having parties with
karaoke machines and booze in Downing
Street and he either didn't know or he
didn't know that was against his own
rules like there's not a there's not a
version of partygate in which Boris
Johnson comes out looking good there's a
version in which he knew what was going
on and lied to the house which is the
bad end of the spectrum and there's one
in which he simply had no idea what was
going on inside his private office in
the building from which he was
commanding the government response to
the pandemic which is also like not
brilliant also the important thing to
bear in mind about the committee report
is the committee report does not have
any automatic consequences the committee
makes a recommendation and it is the
House of Commons that decides whether or
not to endorse the sanctions recommended
by the committee so ultimately what
Boris is saying is that he doesn't think
that he could have persuaded the House
of Commons which remember has a large
conservative majority which he won he
doesn't think that he could persuade
that House of Commons to reject the
findings that's ultimately it this is
not a sanction from a particular group
of MPS they do that they do the report
and they drop the recommendations but it
is the entire House of Commons that
votes on whether to uphold or reject the
recommendations of the committee and
that is the Judgment that he is fleeing
from by residing his constituency and
what now for him money making circuit
speaking book writing future is that is
that what holds him
I mean yeah for now he's very good at it
uh he'll go and make an awful lot of
money and then I suppose the question is
it's very unlikely that Boris will
vanish from the scene right I think he
actually would probably have had it
proven possible and sustainable he
probably had quite liked to be on the
back benches playing the great Prince
over the water so who knows maybe there
will be some TV station that will find a
birth for him and give him a show he's a
good showman if nothing else I imagine
that we'll still be hearing from him he
might return to his Daily Telegraph
column but he won't vanish but it will
definitely be throwing grenades from the
sidelines for the foreseeable future
and he has a real accusation about
brexit I'm not alone in thinking that
there is a Witch Hunt underway to take
revenge for brexit and ultimately to
reverse the 2016 referendum result my
removal he says is the necessary first
step and I believe there has been a
concerted attempt to bring it back about
do you think there is no is it the case
that the Civil Service elements of the
Civil Service had difficulty adjusting
to the change of what was 40 Years of
British policy absolutely are there very
real problems with this with the Civil
Service in specific areas like the home
office that need addressing yes but what
brought Boris Johnson down was that 50
of his own ministers that he appointed
from his party resigned that's why he
had to go is he suggesting that his own
government of his own ministers were
complicit in this Civil Service plot I'm
sorry it's ridiculous it's an absolutely
ridiculous allegation fundamentally
there are specific problems which are
not helped by Boris Johnson inflating
the in this way but the reason he had to
resigned as prime minister is because he
lost the confidence of the conservative
MPS that worked with him day in and day
out many of whom owed him their seats in
as much as they won their seats in 2019
so we should not give Credence to these
conspiracy theories
he's had three bites at the
Parliamentary Cherry has he not first
selected as a Conservative candidate for
clued South back in 1997 lost to labor
that Landslide obviously for Tony Blair
2001 stood again winning in Henley on
Thames re-elected 2005. then of course
as we remember stood as mayor of London
in a narrow Victory beating uh the
sitting Ken Livingston winning again uh
as mayor in 2012 returned to Parliament
in 2015 winning the current seat that
he's now resigning from Oxbridge and
South ruislab could he come back once
more do you think Henry
I mean yeah he could he's Boris Johnson
of course he could yeah Anything could
happen I I refuse to say that he's gone
forever because I've said it before and
I've always been wrong frankly I think
if he'd fought this by-election there's
a decent chance that he might have won
it and that would have immediately
transformed the entire narrative around
Boris Johnson so are there circumstances
in which he comes back at some point
especially if the conservatives spend a
long time in the wilderness after they
lose quite possibly is it likely at this
point I don't think so
Henry Hill good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed a statement from Jacob
Reese smog one of those who's benefited
from the uh Johnson honors list
announced today the early statements by
Harriet Harman always risked a partial
report she has damaged the standing of
the commons by her involvement when she
judged Boris before hearing a word of
evidence well let's talk now to Aleister
Campbell who was Tony Blair's
spokesperson when he was prime minister
should Harriet Harman have recused
herself from this investigation
no and remember this is as the previous
speaker and your correspondent Sam both
said this is a Tory majority committee
but you've got extraordinary coincidence
going on today you've got Donald Trump
in America and Boris Johnson in London
doing exactly the same game which is
basically doing what they've done all
their life lying not facing up to their
own responsibilities and having their
enablers pretend that they were ever fit
for public office Boris Johnson anybody
who's ever known Boris Johnson
knows that the guy was a liar a
charlatan utterly unfit for public
office he's done fundamental damage to
the country he's done fundamental damage
to the standards in public life and his
letter is statement tonight is utterly
trumpian it blames everybody but himself
it rewrites history and the sooner this
turd is flushed down the toilet the
better and I was interested in what Sam
said he said of course the media loved
Boris Johnson that has been part of the
problem through this whole story Boris
Johnson is has never been fit for public
office there is and what he's doing
tonight is trying to create the next
chapter in The Narrative of Boris
Johnson and have his enablers and
friends in the media and a dwindling
bunch of politicians try to Peddle that
narrative to the British public and I
hope that finally the British public
like I've seen through it and I think
they have I think Boris Jones I agree
with the previous speaker Henry Hill I
think the guy's finished he will carry
on being a noise he will carrying on as
Henry said throwing hand grenades he
will go off and do what he's always done
look after his own interests like Trump
he cares about one thing and one thing
only and that is himself well to be fair
it's not the media is it it's been the
public on a number of occasions you know
he describes in this statement uh the
massive majority had the biggest since
the 1990s as you know he he won in labor
London twice against him a sitting Ken
Livingston you know the guys the guy's a
winner in the country that's the point
isn't it well he's won elections for
sure won an election as mayor as you say
and what is effectively generally seen
as a as a progressive City and that's
because he pretended to be a progressive
he won the referendum by lying he won
the referendum by pretending to
something that to be something that he
wasn't he won the general election by
saying that he would get brexit done
with his haven't really deal that was
nothing but was anything but he won
against Jeremy corbyn and as again as
Sam and Henry were saying he's now
decided that actually he's probably
better served for himself which as I say
is all he cares about by trying to
preserve the myth of the winner which
you are continuing to say if Boris
Johnson had hung around he got a spelled
he got kicked out of his own party he's
now been found by a committee of MPS
which includes as I say a majority of
conservative MPS but he can't face that
truth he can't face that reality so he
has to make it about Harriet Harman who
has done far more distinguished Public
Service than this guy's ever even
dreamed of doing and a number of
conservative MPS and SNP who are
basically saying whatever you were
saying in the House of Commons and in
the public at the time if if a judge May
deeply prejudicial comments about
somebody before casting their you know
their judgment you know they would be
thrown out and this is the accusation he
has against people like Harriet Harman
and other members of the committee who
he said had already expressed deeply
prejudicial remarks about my guilt
before they'd even seen the evidence he
said I did not lie and I know you've
called him a liar I'm just you know
countering that with his statement I did
not lie and I believe that in their
hearts the committee know it they've
willfully chosen to ignore the truth
because from the outside their purpose
has not been to discover the truth or
genuinely genuinely to understand what
was in my mind when I spoke in the
Commons
well that is classic trumpian johnsonism
that's what they do
the guy look you so he is basically
saying that every single mp on that
committee is incapable of making their
own mind up about factors they are
presented to them
you're showing pictures now of the
committee inquiry they sat there for
several hours they looked him in the eye
they listened to his answers they set it
they set those answers against the facts
as they knew them from what had been
happening from other people who'd been
giving them stating what had happened in
in so-called partygate and I honestly
think this I really do think this is
part of the problem
it's that the guy what come when when we
talk about Putin at the moment we all
say on the media Putin a proven liar we
have to be surely your professionals to
face up to this the guy is a proven liar
has been for many years and yet you
continue to treat him like some kind of
exotic Showbiz character what this
committee should do is make sure that he
this report should do is make sure that
this guy's expelled from public life for
good he has done so much damage to this
country and he is continuing to to do
that damage by the conduct that he's
displaying tonight are you sure you're
one of those people who are you know
doing a Witch Hunt to take revenge for
brexit and reverse the referendum result
which is the other accusation he's made
tonight well of course he is of course
he is because that is who and what he is
he cannot face the fact that he has
finally after years as a journalist
being a liar after years as a politician
being a liar that he's been found out
and I agree with both Sam and with Henry
that he'll try to come back he did I
don't think he models himself on Trump
he models himself on somebody like
Berlusconi he thinks that he's got a
character and a personality that people
like and you keep telling me he's a
winner I mean did you take a look at his
ratings During the period which led up
to his defense did you expect him to win
an 80 seat majority at the last election
I know he did no but did you expect him
to you didn't did you you know we saw
the celebrations for Blythe Valley with
him and and Carrie when they won it they
didn't expect to win an 80s majority
it's not a myth no he won that election
he won that election because he was up
against the labor party that frankly was
not going to be elected at that time I
think the next time can be and he won
because just as he'd won the referendum
on I think many many lies he had a very
powerful clear message that he was going
to vote for me and I'll get brexit done
and then this letter tonight and his
attack on Rishi sunak I don't have much
time for Rishi sunak I think in Mrs
Thatcher's government he'd have been a
middle ranking minister in a middle
ranking department but he's better than
Johnson and what he's doing tonight is
basically saying all of those things
that I didn't manage to get done you're
not getting managed managing to get them
done either and I'm going to give you a
hard time over it please will you stop
treating this guy like he's a normal
politician he's a liar he's a charlatan
he's been found out and the sooner he is
gone from our screens and we can stop
talking about him and Trump who between
them have done so much damage to
politics
the better we'll all be yeah she's got
lots of reaction coming in good to have
you on thank you very much indeed
clearly Boris Johnson has denied all
those allegations of lying he says that
the uh the committee willfully has not
believed his truth
um let's just bring you some more
reaction getting lots of it newly
knighted MP Simon Clark this is the very
definition of a kangaroo court uh
Michael fabricant also benefiting from
that honors list today very supportive
Boris Johnson during partygate in fact
disgraceful treatment of a political
leader who has made world history by
achieving brexit and leading the
conservatives to a landslide general
election Victory
um Mark jenkinson Against All Odds an
80-seat conservative majority turned
workington man out to vote for me and
delivered brexit at the critical end now
the SNP good riddance no one in Scotland
will shed a tear to see the back of
Boris Johnson this is the s p
Westminster leader Stephen Flynn MP the
SNP will be working hard for every vote
at the next election so Scotland can get
rid of these this rotten Tory
governments for good with Independence
uh as I said more reaction coming
through Christian wakeford who caused
shock when he defected from Troy to
labor in 2022 tweeted goodbye Boris
Johnson I can't say you'll be much
missed and so it goes on let's go back
to Sam coats our Deputy political editor
what is the tenor then of the of the
reaction you're hearing Sam
so I think when you when you read it out
there is shock and sadness and anger
amongst allies of Boris Johnson but but
it doesn't feel like it is so incendiary
at the moment that this is the beginning
of an uncontrollable Civil War and and
if this is the end of Boris Johnson in
the House of Commons as it looks like it
may well be then it's not quite clear
how much
political traction he can get going uh
anytime soon the reason I said it looks
probably like is because there's one
small Nuance which is you know we've had
two MPS resigned today one is Boris
Johnson the other a few hours ago is
Nadine Doris uh the mid beds MP she uh
quit just hours after saying that she
wasn't going to quit she's clearly quite
a close Ally uh of Boris Johnson
um there is some kind of speculation
simply because
uh there is a vacancy uh that Boris
Johnson could sort of in some way having
quit from uh the Uxbridge seat then go
across to the mid uh bedfordshire seat
and try and fight that now I I get the
impression down the street don't want
that we're trying to find out the extent
to which Downing Street control that
decision uh but could there be something
like that but if it's not he he's out
he's out of parliament so so that
provides a kind of ceiling to the kind
of
um uh kind of momentum that Boris
Johnson's resignation could
um could could trigger because I think
the question for Tory MPS is do they
want to agree with this line of argument
now it's a I'm going to read you
something from somebody called Peter
Kratos Lord krudus and and Peter crutus
is a big Ally of Boris Johnson and this
is how he and some around Boris Johnson
frame what's happened today he said
Parliament just put two fingers up to
the British electorate and said that we
don't care who you voted for all the
manifesto we're in charge and we will do
what we want Parliament have forced out
a democratically elected pm and MP and
his Manifesto democracy is dead so the
question for Tory MPS is do they agree
with that do they agree with an ally of
Boris Johnson and and implicit in Boris
Johnson's argument in his own
resignation letter that what has
happened today is fundamentally
anti-democratic or do they think that
having been slung out of parliament by
uh slung out of number 10 by uh a
conservative party and now being uh uh
kind of as it were found guilty of lying
to Parliament by a tory-led privileges
committee and then going to have to go
to the constituents in his actual
constituency uh and fight for his
survival uh just as an MP uh has he not
concluded that the risks of those things
are too much so it is his unwillingness
to face democracy that's the issue here
and and I think it's that choice that
means that perhaps some MPS aren't
coming out harder yes there might be
more Tory MPS quitting at some point
soon uh to to give this whole thing
momentum uh yes there is a small chance
that against standing Street's wishes uh
Boris Johnson tries to convince the mid
beds uh conservative of Association that
he he should immediately return to
Parliament but is that really the future
that Boris Johnson wants is that really
a sort of a person who probably has no
path back to the leadership hanging
around fighting uh fighting a a seat uh
becoming an MP but remaining about
Venture and perpetually being an
irritant of whoever is either a number
10 or just simply the conservative party
that is that the future he wants or by
quitting now and creating the myth
around what's happened to him isn't that
a better option as he goes off and
spends more time making money uh doing
speeches writing comments I mean who
knows maybe he could be part of a bid to
buy The Daily Telegraph which appears to
be up for sale at the moment that he's
got plenty of money rolling in the
opportunities are a boundless then he
has his own media platform uh itself so
um I think I I think there might
actually just be more a more attractive
life for Boris Johnson outside
Parliament and you know there are 20 40
60 very vocal conservative MPS who like
Boris Johnson respect Boris Johnson are
horrified by the way that their own
party frankly has treated him but there
are
um of course 300 plus Tory MPS and a
much larger number who are not running
to defend him tonight on the ground that
they know that to mount two vigorous of
Defense of Boris Johnson is effectively
to cause problems for Richie sunac they
know that Britain goes to the polls next
year for a general election which could
see the conservative the biggest risk of
the conservatives losing power since
2010 they know that prolonged infighting
does not help and however much
um uh Boris Johnson who feels deeply
injured as you heard him say to James
Matthews the sky correspondent an
extraordinary and glorious confrontation
uh in an American airport he feels wrong
he feels he's been hard done by but you
know he feel feels hard done by by
processes that are voted on and endorsed
by MPS regularly who take part in the
systems by which Boris Johnson has been
um uh sort of found found to have lied
to the houses of Parliament so you know
is it actually the case that Boris
Johnson's just running away
um because he his alternative to doing
what he did tonight was to receive the
verdict of the Privileges committee that
he appeared in front of a few weeks ago
uh see how MPS vote see how many MPS on
his own side vote for him and for the uh
for what he believes in uh and try and
Stave off an absolute humiliating end
potential end to a political career that
saw him reach at the very top of
politics instead he's trying to frame
his own exit uh and uh go out with a pop
maintain his relevance uh and um ensure
that he continues to be talked about
um it has been an absolutely
extraordinary roller coaster but it does
feel like the roller coaster is about to
pause politically at least for some time
Sam for the moment thank you a statement
from the chair of Boris Johnson's local
conservative Association councilor
Richard Mills it has been an honor and
privilege to have been able to work with
Boris Johnson since he was first elected
as our MP in 2015. contrary to external
perception his commitment to the
constituency over the last eight years
has been outstanding and he has
delivered for the communities across
Uxbridge and South ruislip we respect
his decision to stand down as our local
MP in response to the outcomes proposed
by the Parliamentary privileges
Committee in a coordinated campaign
against him reiterating Boris Johnson's
own statement there Sam I think you've
got more for us tell us more so the one
thing that people are discussing tonight
is whether or not Boris Johnson could do
a Rat Run basically having quit Uxbridge
go and try and be an MP in adding Doris
seat of mid beds I've just uh had a
message from somebody inside the
conservative Association at mids beds
they believe having talked to people
there is no chance of Johnson going
there the local Association has a good
list of potential local candidates and
they think they're very determined to
make their own choice and it won't be
him they've been anticipating this and
they are not stupid so that's a message
from somebody in the mid beds uh
conservative Association looking to
largely shut the door on Boris Johnson
doing that rat run which would represent
the last chance of him coming into
Parliament back to Parliament you know
in it for it for any time soon so uh it
does look like it's farewell to Boris
Johnson from Frontline politics for the
time being
let's bring a now writer and journalist
Harry Mount who amongst other things is
the author of The Wit and wisdom of
Boris Johnson good to see you I've just
got the front page of tomorrow's sun in
front of me Bojo I quit a raging Boris
Johnson last night sensationally quit as
a Tory MP after learning the findings of
a kangaroo court inquiry into partygate
your reaction
well that statement is astonishing that
Boris one of the things he does uh In
the Flesh and on the page is always
cover up his real Thoughts with a mask
that birdie Worcester mask I've never
seen him write anything so angry
normally a resigning MP lies through his
teeth and says I'd like to support the
current prime minister in this case
Rishi sunak he doesn't bother with that
he does a fairly uh thinly veiled attack
on Rishi sunak he's spitting blood
because he has always thought not only
did you want to become Prime Minister
but he wanted to become a great prime
minister and there's no chance of that
and I'd have thought it's highly
unlikely he'll ever make a comeback
he wanted to be Churchill did he
he wanted to be Churchill he famously
his earliest recorded saying to his
sister Rachel Johnson was he wanted to
be World King and he's not going to be
that and uh I heard that as recently as
February he was thinking he might be
able to get come back as prime minister
relatively soon well that's all over I
also heard rumors that people were
saying that the Privileges committee
would just give him a slap on the wrist
which clearly isn't the case we haven't
yet seen their report of course but he
obviously has heard or heard the summary
of it so it's an extraordinary shock
both the fact that uh the committee is
uh has obviously given a big big
suspension and also the anger of his
resignation statement why did he blow it
then and was he always going to blow it
Boris is a keen uh classicist and he
will know that uh great people as he
sees himself as one are brought down by
hubris but also the uh Greek word
hamatia a fatal flaw and Boris is this
very clever very funny person but he
does have a fatal flaws he's not great
at uh telling the truth and also I think
his downfall goes back to his failure to
discipline Owen Patterson in 2021 he's
not good at turning people off which is
is nice in the flesh but not good as a
prime minister that was followed up by
partygate I've heard that he's kicking
himself that he didn't just make
guidelines about a gather of social
Gatherings rather than laws if you make
a law and then break it yourself then of
course
um you're finished and then the third
thing was his failure to discipline
Chris uh Pinscher in so-called grouper
Gates and that in a way is fatal flaw is
his uh kind of inability to tell people
off difficulty with the truth and um and
not really being able to impose
discipline
well indeed the the front page of
today's Telegraph started talking about
Boris Johnson might be spared a
by-election on whatever sanction is
thrown his way by the Privileges
committee suggesting they'd learned
their lesson
um about how MPS vote about this uh in
the effort to save the career of Von
Patterson which became a three-line whip
for the conservative party and caused a
great deal of concern and as you said
you know began the rot which followed
didn't it
that's right yeah and combined with I
mean any prime minister would find
covert difficult but uh uh he obviously
did break the rules there um he is
trying to get off by saying he didn't
knowingly do it and there's no way
anyone can prove what's going in
somebody's going on in somebody's mind I
thought he probably did know he was
breaking the rules if he'd said to begin
with I did this it was wrong he might
have got off but I'm afraid he he very
often tells a quick lie to get off the
hook and normally that doesn't matter
and he's had so many comebacks I met
someone who was at school with him who
said age 13 he thought he'd never do
well in his o levels because he was
doing too much extracurricular activity
and he kept on saying the school friend
he's never going to become an MP he's
never going to become better The
Spectator each time he was proved wrong
so you write him off it as Peril but I
think the tenor of that resignation
letter shows that he's decided he's
finished because he's really poisoned
his relationships not just with Richie
sunac but with lots of the conservative
party apart from his die-hard supporters
hormont thank you very much Judy good to
have you on there more reaction let's
listen now to Labor's Emily Thornbury
Shadow Attorney General
well I don't know about all this so pot
Pro what I do know about is that the
people are completely Fed Up about this
roller coaster of chaos and incompetence
that they've been witnessing
they will get a chance in the near
future to be able to express themselves
and I'm quite sure that they will be
showing just how disgusted they are with
all of this it doesn't seem to matter
what leader they get it just continues
to be chaos
he says it's a Witch Hunt to get him out
of parliament do you do you agree with
that is there is there a Witch Hunt
going on it does sometimes look like one
I think that Boris Johnson has brought
all this on himself but you know it's a
support Pro what the public wants to
know about is who is going to look after
their interests who's going to be
actually interested in in in the cost of
living in looking after all hospitals in
making sure that we fight crime on our
streets that's what should be important
not all this nonsense not all this chaos
and not all this corruption does this
have any implications for Rishi sunak
I think the all it shows is that it
doesn't matter who is in charge
the chaos and the corruption continues
the soap opera continues that people
want to have someone who is going to
look after them and look after their
interests who's going to focus on the
cost of living is going to be fixing our
hospitals going to be fighting crime on
our streets uh what do you think of uh
Mr Johnson's resignation on his list
I think that Boris Johnson's resignation
on his list is exactly what we were
expecting
it is I think just fits in with the
chaos and the corruption that I've been
talking about it seems to me that we
need to move on and whenever I speak to
anybody they are desperate to see the
back of this lot they are desperate to
see a back of the chaos and the
corruption that this government have
brought us and they want to have one
that's going to look after them
and just finally what chances do labor
have in that by-election it's an
extremely conservative area that's an
understatement what do you think your
hopes are honestly
if you look at the polling the re sorry
if you look at the recent polling the
seat by seat polling we are not only in
second place we are really close so we
have a very good chance of beating the
conservatives in mid-beds and not least
because the public are fed up with
having a government that is ignoring
them and they are fed up with having
Nadine Doris who in turn has been
ignoring them but we are an alternative
and our priorities are the people's
priorities which is fixing hospitals
which is fighting crime in our streets
and looking after people because of the
cost of living crisis
foreign
there so let's return to our Deputy
political editor Sam Kurtz when do we
get to see this privileges committee
report that may have recommended a
sanction of 10 days which could have uh
if circumstances have been different
have triggered this by-election in that
seat Sam
um well in his letter Boris Johnson
suggests that maybe we should bring to
an end or the committee should bring to
an end the process of the Privileges
committee but it doesn't feel tonight
like that's going to happen in other
words probably in the next week or so
we'll see uh the report it was due to be
voted on if Boris Johnson hadn't quit
tonight uh in a couple of weeks time
that vote seemingly no longer necessary
but it would have to be in public you
know for a good you know week to 10 days
before that vote in order uh to give
everybody a chance to see it
um so that will be a moment of Reckoning
as well looking at Tory party reaction
again very strident allies of Boris
Johnson clearly disappointed but not
absolutely going to war just to conclude
with uh pretty Patel statement Boris
Johnson served our country within his
constituency with distinction he led the
world in supporting Ukraine got brexit
done and was the most electorally
successful prime minister since Margaret
Thatcher Boris is a political Titan
whose Legacy will stand the test of time
a heartfelt tribute there from pretty
Patel which you can see on the screen
but not an attack on Rishi sunak not a
declaration of war doesn't seek to
deepen the pain inside the conservative
party that looks to me like some allies
of Boris Johnson perfectly willing to
draw a line under this episode rather
than man the barricades and start a new
Civil War so depending on uh quite what
happens next this could be Boris Johnson
leaving the political stage creating a
bit more breathing space for Rishi sunak
because everything that Boris Johnson
has touched since Richie sunac has been
in uh has been in number 10 has made
life more difficult for the incumbent
Sam at the moment thanks very much
indeed let's talk now to James Johnson
who was a special advisor to Theresa May
um well your reaction to Boris Johnson
first of all and then my follow-up
question would be is this the end of the
johnsonites effectively do you think
leaving Parliament
I think I think this is the end of Boris
Johnson and I think it's the end of the
Johnson lights I actually think really
Boris Johnson's career was over in
January 2022 when those party gate uh
Revelations really came out that's when
we saw amongst the public
um in our polling a huge turn against
him they decided he had lied they
decided he was not fit for office and
since then Boris Johnson has been a
toxic electoral asset for the
conservatives I think what we see today
is the culmination of that story and an
indication from Boris Johnson that he
knew full well that he wouldn't be able
to win that by-election if it had taken
place in Uxbridge in a few weeks time
and so what do you think about the
statement and the swipes he's made
against the current prime minister and
the government specifically things like
why if they abandoned a free trade deal
with America you know animal rights
housing pro-growth low tax the sort of
Liz truss agenda you know is that a
final flutter of whatever he believed in
do you think I think this is Boris
Johnson lashing out in the final days uh
in the final day uh Boris Johnson talks
in that letter um about the lack of
achievements made he talks about uh the
conservatives being at risk of losing
his majority now it's absolutely true
that Boris Johnson did win that big
majority in 2019 and he had an appeal to
the British public but since those party
gate Revelations the public turned
against him and if you look at the
conservative ratings over the last few
uh years and months yes obviously Liz
truss uh made things a lot worse but
really I think it's hard to look at the
last couple of years without seeing
Boris Johnson sort of taking a
sledgehammer to the Tory brand he caused
that chaos there's not much of a legacy
for him to talk about apart from the
delivery of brexit which you know six in
ten voters feel is going extremely badly
um and uh I think that's the situation
uh that we're now in I do think Sam
coaches analysis is correct though um
that I think this actually gives Rishi
sunx a breathing space yes there are a
few of those die-hard Boris fans who
will stick by him whatever but they're
not a majority in the party they're not
even anything close to a sizable
minority
or breathing space apart from two
by-elections to come which you know
looking at the polls won't be pretty for
anybody in the conservative party
these are going to be very difficult
very difficult by elections for the
conservatives especially in Oxbridge I
think we can say you can never never
predict with certainty in British
politics but I think it would be
extremely extremely uh likely for labor
to gain that seat in Oxbridge uh mid
bedfordshire a little bit harder for for
laborer that have damaged to gain it but
if there is some kind of a Pax between
labor and the lib Dems then yes we will
see uh that happen but look when people
uh are looking at politics and they're
looking at the conservative government
whenever Boris Johnson has popped up
over the last few months it has caused
the conservatives ratings to fall
if this is truly the end of Boris
Johnson and I think all of the
indications are that it is then that may
well uh finally for Richie sunac stop
happening and they can focus on actually
trying to win the next election
well his statement on his legacy I am
very sorry to leave my wonderful
constituency it's been a huge honor to
serve them both as a mayor and MP I am
proud that after what is cumulatively a
15-year stint I've helped to deliver
among other things a vast new Railway in
the Elizabeth line and full funding for
a wonderful new state of the art
hospital for Hillingdon where enabling
Works have already begun this is the
local staff I'm also hugely proud of all
that we achieved in my time as prime
minister getting brexit done winning the
biggest majority for 40 years and
delivering the fastest vaccine rollout
of any major European country as well as
leading Global support for Ukraine but
if this is his political obituary what
do you think it should be
well I think you know a lot a lot of
those things are right the vaccine
rollout was extremely effective Boris
Johnson did lead the world on Ukraine
um but as far as the public was
concerned that all changed in 2022 and
uh I think his legacy is will inevitably
be somebody who won an ATC majority for
the conservatives and then proceeded to
slowly and methodically throw it away
through his own behavior and I think
that's the real tragedy for the
conservative party of the last few years
as I say yes Liz trust didn't make
matters worse yes labor getting rid of
corbyn obviously made made things better
for labor but I think that Boris Johnson
May well be remembered as the uh the
arch Saboteur of the conservative party
who delivered its biggest Victory but
also significantly diminished it and um
Aleister Campbell uh Drew parallels with
what's happening uh on the other side of
the Atlantic proven liar Trump and he
said proven liar Boris both crying foul
and Witch Hunt do you see similarities
I think it's quite different I think
obviously it's a criminal uh proceedings
in the United States against against
Donald Trump which obviously makes
things different but we've always seen
in our polling that there is a
difference between Boris Johnson and
Donald Trump's popularity in America
there is that there is that chunk of 20
30 of Voters who will stick by Donald
Trump no matter what even possibly after
this indictment today in the UK that
same set of loyalty uh doesn't stand for
Donald Trump so it doesn't stand for
Boris Jones I'm sorry so I don't I don't
really like these comparisons I think uh
the Trump Boris thing is a little lazy I
think Boris clearly has you know has you
know led the world on things like
Ukraine in a way that Trump clearly
clearly hasn't
um but uh I think the real difference is
is the level of support that they have
Trump can rely on that enthusiasm from
his voters Boris Khan
James Johnson uh former special advisor
oh sorry you were a special former
special advisor to uh Theresa May I
suddenly started saying that you were a
current advisor thank you very much
indeed for your time well let's bring in
our political editor Beth Rigby with her
assessment and whatever your thoughts
are Boris Johnson you know he has been a
Titan of British politics Beth
that's quite right and I mean if we
pause and reflect whatever the rights or
wrongs of Boris Johnson how he conducted
himself in office as he notes in his own
uh letter where he announces he's quit
he delivered uh one of the biggest
conservative majorities or the biggest
conservative majority uh since Margaret
Thatcher he got brexit over the line and
all of that he is a significant figure
and in fact you're talking about him
being a Titan uh pretty Patel the former
home secretary that he's just enabled in
his honors list as has has uh put out a
statement on Twitter tonight saying
Johnson has served our country in his
constituency with distinction he led
what the world in support in Ukraine Got
uh brexit done and was our most
electorally successful prime minister
since Thatcher Boris is a political
Titan whose Legacy will stand the test
of time I think Anna in all of this I
I'd say three things one I think there's
genuine surprise in Westminster tonight
even his closest allies that I had
spoken to were not expecting it coming
why has he done it he's preempting uh
the committee he does not want to have
to be forced out in a humiliating vote
in the House of Commons and be suspended
so he has taken the initiative going on
his terms he's clearly Furious about
what has happened and takes aim not just
at the Privileges committee but also at
Rishi sunak and when you dive into that
letter he could not be more critical of
his successor and I think the question
there is in what way that opens up the
fragile piece and the conservative party
now uh divided parties do not win
elections the party's been pretty
disciplined after trust and you know
there is a sense that the Boris Johnson
star within the Parliamentary parties on
the way but you know a former prime
minister so publicly calling out
everything he thinks wrong is wrong with
Rishi sunak's regime in a way that
others agree being it not getting brexit
done properly or not getting the Free
Trade Agreement or not cutting taxes
that really is throwing the gauntlet
down uh to Rishi sunak and that is
politically uncomfortable I think the
final thing to say is in the letter he
says he is sorry to leave Parliament for
now and this is a politician who is
leaving the door open to a return as Sam
was saying he's heard from mid beds
where Nadine Doris is uh MP that they
are not minded this is one person within
that Association to get Boris Johnson
into that seat but there's a question
about whether he returns in that seat
does he try and return into another
parliamentary seat uh before the next
general election does he take up a
column in the Daily Telegraph and just
throw stones in and rocks him from the
outside on Rishi sunak uh but wherever
which way this is a massive uh moment in
in British politics and I think the big
question tonight is what will Boris
Johnson do next because this is a
politician who whether you love him or
loves him has huge impact on the
national stage and he is going out uh
not with a whimper but with a bang and
that is a letter of a politician and a
an operative an operator uh who still
wants impact and wants to be seen and
heard so I think that this is
difficult for if she's not given that he
put out the honors list in order to try
and cement a kind of peace deal with
Boris Johnson and in this resignation
resignation letter uh Boris Johnson is
openly Going To War uh with the sunat
regime how he comes back and whether he
does remains to be seen but there's
what's for sure in all of this is Boris
Johnson is going to take up a lot of
attention uh in what he does next
better Rigby our political editor with
her assessment thank you very much
indeed so Boris Johnson is resigning as
an MP after accusing a Commons
investigation into whether he misled
Parliament over partygate of attempting
to drive me out as he put it he compared
the probe to a kangaroo court as he
announced his intention to step down as
MP for Uxbridge and South ruislip for
reaction obviously coming up in Sky News
at term he believed it was determined to
use the proceedings against me to drive
me out of parliament more to come
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story former prime minister
Boris Johnson quits as an MP after being
told he'll be sanctioned for misleading
Parliament over partygate he says he is
bewildered and appalled describing the
committee investigation as a kangaroo
court mounting a political hit job
the news are shocked to Westminster with
government whips given no notice of the
resignation we'll be live tonight in
Downing Street and the former prime
minister's constituency
also tonight the classified documents
which could send former U.S president
Donald Trump to prison today an indict
moves unsealed charging Donald J Trump
with felony violations of our national
security laws as well as participating
in a conspiracy to obstruct Justice
the nurse accused of murdering seven
babies described as a calculated liar in
court after denying having an affair
with a married colleague
a message of defiance from the Israeli
Prime Minister in the face of a new
Iranian threat everybody says we're
going to decapitate you what will I talk
about the method of our decapitation
we're going to destroy you the method of
our destruction
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
foreign
good evening the former prime minister
Boris Johnson angrily resigned as an MP
this evening bringing an end to a
colorful and tumultuous political career
spanning nearly two decades he stands
down in his Uxbridge and South ruislip
constituency after being told he would
be sanctioned by the Privileges
committee for knowingly and recklessly
misleading Parliament about parties in
Downing street during lockdown an
excoriating statement Mr Johnson said he
did not lie and took aim of what he
called a kangaroo court determined to
find him guilty we'll have more on what
his resignation could mean for his
career and the future of the
conservative party in a moment but first
our political correspondent Liz Bates
has this report
Boris Johnson who nine months ago was
prime minister has quit as an MP
in a long angry statement he blamed the
Privileges committee that investigated
him over partygate on learning they
wanted to see him suspended for over 10
days which could have seen him kicked
out of the commons he stood down
branding it a kangaroo court he thrives
on the oxygen of publicity so what on
Earth he'll do next I do not know in
some ways I don't care but I do actually
because I care passionately about having
people involved in politics that are
decent and honest and honorable and
don't tell lies and that is not that man
Boris Johnson it comes amid a standoff
with the cabinet office over their
handling of his covid Communications
that has seen him once again in the
spotlight
and his resignation honors list added to
the controversy with his old Ally Nadine
Doris denied a peerage also dramatically
standing down just hours earlier
something significant did happen to
change my mind and you know I'm not
someone who's going to go you know
blabbing at what that was immediately I
need to you know process a few thoughts
and things but um so yeah something
significant did happen to change my mind
and and I did do and I think it's for
the best I didn't want to cause a
by-election but
but you know I've got over myself
frankly in his statement he takes aim at
the current prime minister his record on
brexit and his party's lack of ambition
and things are about to get worse for
Rishi sunak with a by-election now on
the horizon that could inflict another
electoral wound on the conservatives
in the final line of his statement Mr
Johnson says he's going at least for now
a message reminiscent of his last words
in the Commons as prime minister hasta
la vista baby a reminder to his Rivals
he may be leaving Parliament but Boris
Johnson's influence on British politics
is not going anywhere Liz Bates Sky News
Westminster
well our Deputy political editor some
coaches in Downing Street so just how
significant is this then Sam well I know
inside number 10 behind me they're
braced now for a weekend of yet more
turbulence another few days of
conservative psychodrama and they're
having to prepare for two by-elections
neither of which the conservative party
are certain to win one for Nadine Doris
mid bedfordshire seat the other of
course for Boris Johnson but even
despite all of that difficulty I just
wonder whether some inside number 10
think this the preferable path Boris
Johnson could have chosen to remain but
that would have meant seeing the
Privileges committee report come out and
his Tory colleagues having to decide
whether to vote for him and I can tell
you Anna from the conversations that
I've been having although there's a
vocal minority who support him I'm not
sure that vote would have been pretty if
he had lost that vote he then would have
had to face his constituents in Uxbridge
and given there's only a 7 000 majority
there he could have been slung out by
the constituents that he has served for
since 2010 uh and now since 2015. um and
that would be a humiliating end to a
career that's already pretty check it
and even if he'd won that he would be
hanging around in Parliament with
probably no path to ever becoming Tory
leader again just an irritant a ghost at
The Feast for this prime minister and if
the Tories lose the general election uh
next year whoever succeeds Rishi sunak
so Boris Johnson decided to leave that
enables him to write his own story in a
blaze of publicity with the spotlight
shining at him alleging that he was
thwarted by forces that were
anti-democratic I just wonder Anna
whether this outcome as Boris Johnson
goes off to make a lot of money and
doesn't face those humiliations I wonder
whether this outcome quietly satisfies
both Boris Johnson and the people in the
building behind me
Sam coats in Downing Street thank you
well let's cross now to the former prime
minister zarks bridge and South ruislip
constituency Rachel venables is there a
somewhat marginal seat majority of 7 000
now facing a by-election uh what a
voters they have been saying to you this
evening Rachel
well I think a considerable amount of
shock here in Uxbridge yes it has been
throughout the country reverberating
through Whitehall and Beyond Boris
Johnson of course such a Titan of our
politics and of course he's a huge part
of the local politics here he's been the
mp uh foxbridge and South ruislip for a
number of years now but as you mentioned
a marginal seat so this will have Labor
certainly rubbing their hands with Glee
This is a seat they had an eye on even
in the 2019 elections so Boris Johnson
was able to squeak through with the
majority of more than 7 200 that means
labor seems to be in a pretty good
position going forwards this now a seat
of course a Battleground going to be the
source of a by-election now I'm here in
the Town Center on the High Street of
course it's a Friday night and many of
the people I've spoken to actually
hadn't even heard the news that Boris
Johnson had resigned they're just out
enjoying their evening but all of them
expressing shock at the idea that he
could step back appreciation actually
for many of the people I spoke to about
the work that he has done both this
prime minister and as a local Member of
Parliament and of course I think as
always when you have a member of
parliament who is seen on such a
national stage as Boris Johnson was as
prime minister and even after he left I
think people really do appreciate having
somebody like that ask their Member of
Parliament so so far so far just shock
and appreciation for the work that he
has done but I'm sure as the night goes
on and we get more reaction we'll see a
split in the voters and it'll be
fascinating to see what people think
going forwards into the by-election
whether they will stick with the Tories
or whether we could see labor opening up
a gap here and taking this seat is no
doubt they will be hoping to after that
shock announcement from Boris Johnson
that he is stepping down as MP
Rachel thank you
well plenty of political reaction as you
might imagine including from the
opposition here's what the shadow
attorney general Emily Thornbury had to
say
I think that Boris Johnson has brought
all this on himself but you know it's a
soap opera what the public wants to know
about is who is going to look after
their interests who's going to be
actually interested in in in the cost of
living in looking after all hospitals in
making sure that we fight crime on our
streets that's what should be important
not all this nonsense not all this chaos
and not all this corruption
well an extraordinary statement from
Boris Johnson earlier let's take a look
in more detail at some of it he said I
have been an MP since 2001. I take my
responsibilities seriously I did not lie
and I believe that in their hearts the
committee know it but they have
willfully chosen to ignore the truth
because from the outset their purpose
has not been to discover the truth or
genuinely to understand what was in my
mind when I spoke in the Commons their
purpose from the beginning has been to
find me guilty regardless of the facts
this is the very definition of a
kangaroo court it is very sad to be
leaving Parliament at least for now but
above all I am bewildered and appalled
that I can be forced out
anti-democratically by a committee
chaired and managed by Harriet Harman
with such egregious bias
well let's bring in the Tory grandee
Michael heseltine now your reaction then
to this resignation Miss hasseltine
even in his
resignation statement he can't tell the
truth
he isn't being forced out
anti-democratically a select committee
of the commons has decided to tell the
commons their views about his behavior
it is a committed check
with a majority of conservatives and it
would be the House of Commons that would
decide whether he should pay a penalty
not the committee
but the second and overwhelmingly the
most important issue here is that this
is now a vitally important nail in the
brexit coffin because Boris lied about
brexit time and time again
Nigel farage has now admitted that
brexit has failed and the
unforgivable damage to this country that
has been done on the basis of those lies
is actually Incorporated in this one man
his departure is a nail in the brexit
couple
well in saying that you are actually
answering something he put in a
statement I am not alone he said in
thinking that there is a Witch Hunt
underway to take revenge for brexit and
ultimately to reverse the 2016
referendum result my removal is the
necessary first step and I believe there
has been a concerted attempt to bring it
about has there
oh
yeah it is preposterous to think that a
conservative Committee in the House of
Commons is seeking to redress the brexit
issue over the very serious allegations
that the Prime Minister lied to the
House of Commons
he has played his typical game he's
looked at the report he knows the damage
that it will create and so he has
decided to go and avoid the humiliation
of being censored by the Tories in the
House of Commons and possibly fighting a
by-election that he would lose it is
typical
um
jonathonian manipulation of the events
and we've seen it time and time and
again
when Boris Johnson announced his
candidature to become Tory leader you
know the announcement was that he would
be like a chair effectively in Downey
Street should he win why was the toy
party incapable of ensuring that
happened there was a recognition that he
kind of needed support for this job
well the truth is that the prime
minister is immensely powerful once they
have got the job and boys Johnson was
extraordinarily skillful in appealing to
both Tory MPS and to a wider public with
the basic case that um economic problems
the stagnation in living standards was
because of our membership of the
European Union of the bureaucrats of The
Blob as it was called the BBC and all
these people who were identified in
order to persuade a narrow majority of
the British people that if they voted
for brexit the problems would go away
the truth is they haven't gone away
they're getting worse day by day that
anyone who knows anything about what's
going on in this country knows that
brexit is a disaster and the quicker the
truth is told to the British people the
better the chance that we'll restore our
relationship your
how will people remember Boris Johnson
what is his legacy
his legacy is to have broken the
achievement of the Korea governance of
the second half of the 20th century
whether it was hell McMillan or Ted
Heath or Margaret Thatcher
step by step they took us back into the
heart of Europe
and Boris Johnson in a
total travesty of the real world
fractured that Tory achievement
much indeed Michael hesselton there uh
Boris Johnson's statement went on to say
I am afraid I no longer believe that it
is any coincidence that Sue gray who
investigated gatherings in number 10 is
now the chief of staff designate of the
labor leader when I left office last
year the government was only a handful
of points behind in the polls that Gap
has now massively widened the statement
there of Boris Johnson excoriating as it
was in a number of directions we'll
certainly get more reaction to that as
it comes in
let's
foreign